foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear
so as anybody that has Netflix probably
knows I mean Netflix is generally not
the first or the fourth or the ninth or
the 15th or anything uh streaming
service that you would go to when you
were looking specifically like for some
good horror like they do have some good
stuff on there but you know other
streaming services tend to have like a
better selection however uh every now
and then they will surprise me by
platforming a real kind of uh underseen
gem I guess uh I had previously heard
about this movie only really through
Word of Mouth it turned up on a couple
of uh lists of you know best horror
movies that you haven't seen or best
horror movies on Netflix or something
like that and so you know happily I sat
down to watch it and I'm like wow this
is actually really really awesome
so this is a road trip Thriller and it's
called coming home in the dark and it's
from New Zealand and it premiered at the
Sundance Film Festival back in January
of 2021 and then I think came to Netflix
like in Autumn of the same year so
sometimes September October 2021
something like that but I only just now
heard about it like a couple of weeks
ago so I thought I'd go give it a watch
because I you know I saw it recommended
in a lot of places so this was actually
directed by a guy named James Ashcroft
this is his feature length the debut he
had previously only made shorts prior to
this as far as I'm aware and maybe like
an episode of Television
um and the screenplay was actually
penned by him and a guy named Eli Kent
and it was based on a short story from
1995 by a New Zealand author named Owen
Marshall now the story is very very
straightforward and if you are at all
familiar you know with horror of any
kind particularly particular you know
sub genres
um then this setup will be very familiar
to you but I have to say that the
character work in this one is great the
acting is great and it's just like a
brutal very very tense movie and I think
all of those things like make it a
really mesmerizing watch it just kind of
like leaves you really really anxious
and like really unsettled like the whole
time that you're watching it so at the
very beginning of the movie uh we open
on this just awesome like very very
ominous kind of shot and it immediately
sets this whole like disquieting tone
for the whole movie that just it just
maintains the whole time so we see just
like I think it's a Mercedes and it's
clearly sort of abandoned on the side of
the road uh its door is like wide open
and there's this Swatch of like pink
fabric like it looks like it's maybe
from someone's skirt or something and
it's just kind of hanging out the out
the door I was gonna say driver's side
but I guess it's in New Zealand so I
guess it's the passenger side uh and
it's just kind of like a gently
undulating in the breeze
so the camera kind of lingers on this
silent empty car you're presuming it's
empty for a few moments and then like
another vehicle passes by on the road
and Lake doesn't stop and so you know
which is kind of good because the
occupants of that car are just kind of
like oblivious to the foreshadowing like
to their own Fates which is going going
on like right over here like on the
shoulder of the road so we then get
introduced in uh to our main characters
which is like a family of four and
they're on a road trip into these you
know breathtakingly gorgeous like very
craggy mountains of New Zealand so the
dad's name is Alan uh hoganrod is which
is like a Dutch last names they call him
Hoagie and uh he has a wife named Jill
both of them are teachers and they have
two teenage Sons whose names are Micah
and Jordan so for the first few minutes
I mean the movie doesn't spend a lot of
time like it's very economical like with
the character development which is one
of the things that I really liked about
it because really just for the first few
minutes there's kind of like you know
the same way that a lot of these kind of
road trip horror movies you know start
out you kind of have arguments between
the family members in the car just
establishing everyone's personalities
and like their relationships with one
another they're kind of having arguments
over music you know stopping for snacks
and attempting to like play stupid games
just to like pass the time because it's
a long drive so not long after that uh
the family arrives at their destination
and they start kind of hiking into the
Foothills or whatever and there's also a
little bit more like very minimal like
character development kind of hinting at
the different relationships or the
nature of the difference of the
relationships that Hoagie has with his
two sons but it's very very subtle like
I said it's very economical and I really
really liked that now one of the Suns I
think it's Micah he sees what appears to
be like the Silhouettes Of Two Men or
two people like over a ridge like some
distance away and the people are like
waving at them like they're like hey
friends or whatever now Micah does not
like this at all and like seems really
uneasy about this as you would be
because there's like no one else around
but he doesn't say anything to it like
about it to anybody else because he
figures oh well you know they're way
over there maybe they're also hiking and
it's not that big a deal so the family
like eventually they set up kind of a
picnic lunch at a spot on the waterfront
there's kind of like you can tell it's
kind of like a campsite that people use
because there's like a public toilet
like across from the like on the water
like on the other bank but there's
really no other sign of civilization
anywhere other than like you know just
some kind of rudimentary trails and
whatnot so they've only been sitting
there a very brief time when the two men
from the ridge you're presuming that's
who it is uh kind of approach them and
from the first sight of these two uh the
family are like pretty much put on their
guard the first man who's like the one
who does all the Talking is this kind of
lanky white dude with a beard and a
mustache and he has like these really
dark eyes and he has kind of this very
penetrating stare he just gives up he
exudes like kind of a an air of being
dangerous you know what I mean the other
guy is an even taller and even lankier
uh indigenous guy and he just like
barely barely speaks at all so the white
man introduces himself as Mandrake which
you're led to believe is probably not
his real name and His companion as tubs
although like I said Tubbs I don't think
he introduces himself because he does he
does talk but he doesn't talk all that
much so it's pretty immediately clear
that these two are up to no good and
this fact becomes pretty much
indisputable once Mandrake uh produces a
high-powered hunting rifle uh he doesn't
point at anybody at first but he's kind
of got it there and you're just like oh
[ __ ] this is gonna go really really
sideways now he initially implies that
he's just gonna Rob the family in
particular he seems to want their
vehicle now Hoagie and Jill pretty much
immediately acquiesce they're like here
you know it's just a car they throw them
the keys they're like please just take
it but uh the two guys then forced the
family to like lay face down on the
ground and warn them like don't turn
your heads and look at me and this
sequence right here is just one of the
first is the first one of like many
unbearably tense sequences like
everything is shot in either tight
close-ups or is otherwise framed in such
a way that when you're watching it
you're never really entirely sure like
what's gonna happen next like which form
the danger is going to take like which
direction it's gonna come from so it's
really really like a difficult watch
it's like very very anxiety inducing
because you're not entirely sure what
these dudes kind of end game is you know
what I mean so after a very
shocking uh development that I won't
spoil uh which actually serves to let
the viewer know in the most violent way
possible that all bets are now off uh
the criminals then Force the family into
their own vehicle and proceed to take
them on another kind of road trip which
is this this nightmarish Journey that
obviously they were in no way prepared
for now along the way more information
gets revealed about the principal
characters like both the protagonist the
family and the antagonists that kind of
a little bit like muddy the Waters of
morality somewhat I won't go so far as
to say that you grow to sympathize with
the attackers because Mandrake in
particular is like pretty much a
sociopathic monster but as the details
of their backstories and what's hinted
at maybe like some prior knowledge of
Hoagie's history kind of unfolds as The
Story Goes On It starts to become more
obvious that whatever is going on here
it isn't like a stark black and white
type of situation so this movie I mean
at its heart is just it's a very very
simple but it's a very very chillingly
effective Thriller I mean it just cranks
the anxiety level up to 11 from pretty
much the very first frame and just
leaves it there until the end credits
run like I said you just watch it with
kind of like your heart and your mouth
the whole time because you're not
entirely you're not sure what's gonna
happen like I was kind of watching it
and I had kind of like a little bit of a
stomach ache but it also has like
another layer of depth to it it's kind
of seeking to explore I'm trying to like
kind of talk around it so I don't like
spoil too much about it but it's kind of
trying to um explore maybe the manner in
which abuse uh childhood abuse can kind
of like reverberate back on the society
that just stands by and allows it to
happen it also kind of wrestles with
maybe the thorny problem of how many
Shades of Gray there are that separate
the actual doing of evil to you know
actually knowing about the evil and
seeing the evil occurring but being too
cowardly to do anything to stop it like
how like obviously do doing evil is
worse but like how much better is it to
just know that it's going on and not
intervene or at least try to do
something to you know to stop it you
know what I mean now the movie is
actually is certainly vicious and
violent but it's not gory a lot of the
violence is actually implied or kind of
kept mostly off screen and I think that
was a good decision because I think it
made it like a lot more affecting
because you could kind of like fill in
the blanks with your own imagination
just judging by from the people's
reactions and like the sounds and things
like that so in other words this isn't
like torture porn it's not like super
super gory or super graphic or anything
but I think the restraint actually
serves to make the savagery in a little
bit like feel more real to kind of like
put you in it because you never really
get desensitized to it like through
repetition or having it you know having
this thing where it has to keep like
getting more and more vicious like as
the movie goes on so I think it was
better that they kind of kept it you
know in chat back a little bit and
everything is kind of like just kind of
like off camera like I said the acting
here is also just Top Notch uh the cast
is very small but the players are just
all phenomenal I mean particularly
Daniel Gillies who um plays Mandrake and
he's just like so so menacing like from
the second that he comes on and uh Tubbs
he's played by uh Matthias
luafutu I hope I'm pronouncing that
right
um he doesn't talk much but his facial
expressions and like his body language
just convey this great complexity that
in a way like makes him a more
interesting and complex character in
that he doesn't talk so you're like kind
of led to
speculate about what's going on behind
his face you know what I mean now I mean
horror horror movies like this like
horror Thrillers like this are you know
pretty much a sub-genre unto themselves
it's usually called road trip horror or
something like that I mean you have
stuff like The Hills Have Eyes or
um race with the devil road games uh
Death Valley The Hitcher uh California
the one with the k
um breakdown with Kurt Russell Wrong
Turn wolf creek Wolf Creek um Eden Lake
like a bunch of movies like that this is
along those lines but I think that this
sub-genre is so popular because the
premise is so relatable to so many
people and when it's done effectively
like coming home in the dark is I think
movies like this have the potential to
be like really really terrifying because
we can obviously there's nothing
Supernatural or anything like that you
can imagine yourself thrust into these
same horrible Grim circumstances like as
the characters in the movies are so
coming home in the dark really does
carry on this you know storied tradition
of this road trip horror and it's just
this very lean mean movie it's just
completely nerve jangling like the whole
entire time just keeps you on the edge
of your chair because you're just like
expecting the worst and like I said
you're not really sure what the I mean
you kind of know what the dude's
motivations are but not exactly and you
don't really know like what they hope to
achieve by what it is they're doing so
you're always just kind of like on edge
like seeing what's gonna happen next and
it also has a little bit more of like a
nuanced approach to It's supposed heroes
and villains and kind of like has a more
of like a depth to it than maybe just
like a straightforward good guy bad guy
kind of uh kind of dynamic so I mean
it's definitely one of the better new
horror films that I've seen turn up on
Netflix like in quite a while and man
like I'd recommend it to pretty much
anybody who loves like a really good
genuinely frightening Thriller you know
about essentially like I said a hapless
family that's terrorized by Psychopaths
but has a little bit more going on to it
as well it's really really good so that
will do it for this flickers of fear
hope you enjoyed it and I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye